j'ai
l'honneur au nom du Gouvernement de la
République de demander à l'Assemblée
nationale l'abolition de la peine de
mort en
France bonsoir à tous la France a perdu
l'une de ses plus grandes figures
politiques et intellectuelles Robert
Badinter est mort à l'âge de 95 ans la
nuit dernière une vie de combat pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort les
droits de l'homme les lumières une
conscience républicaine l'esprit
français écrit aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron bienvenue dans cette émission
spéciale qui lui est consacré ce soir
dans sa vous regarde sur LCP qui
commence tout de
[Musique]
suite un hommage national lui sera donc
rendu dans les prochains jours Robert
les prix de justice aux multiples
combats étaent devenu pour les Français
une référence morale rien que ça on va
revenir sur l'avocat le ministre
l'intellectuel le grand républicain
qu'il était avec nos invités bonsoir
Michel cota bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau la journaliste
que vous êtes là évidemment très bien
connu rencontré de très nombreuses fois
vous le racontez d'ailleurs à la fois
dans vos cahers secret de la 5e
République chez Fayard mais aussi dans
ma 5e chez bouquin qui vient de paraître
bon bonsoir Paul Cassia bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver également professeur de
droit public à la Sorbonne vous l'avez
vous aussi rencontré Robert Badinter
tous les mois pendant 1 an pour écrire
une biographie intellectuelle un juriste
en politique chez Fayard c'était en
28 et bonsoir Jean garig bienvenue à
vous vous êtes historien spécialiste de
l'histoire politique et parlementaire
Badinter était d'ailleurs un grand
passionné d'histoire enfin bonsoir
Bertrand Perrier maître Perrier avocat
après la Cour de cassation spécialiste
de l'art oratoire vous revenez
d'ailleurs longuement dans votre dernier
livre sur le discours de Robert Badinter
de 1981 dans la parole pour le meilleur
et pour le pire publié chez jicates on
en avait parlé ici même je vous donne la
parole à tous les cas dans un tout petit
instant mais d'abord on va revenir sur
ce parcours
extraordinaire une vie de combat c'est
signéamondava
mesdames messieurs les
députés le 17 septembre
1981 Robert badter est à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale l'abolition de la
peine de mort c'est le combat de toute
sa vie
demain grâce à
vous la justice
française ne sera plus une justice qui
tu législateur
français de tout mon cœur je vous
remercie il s'agissait de décider d'une
vie humaine et que cette vie humaine on
ne doit pas à la retranché j'ai eu un
instant je le dis très simplement
d'émotion parce que c'était la fin de la
marche cette conviction Robert Badinter
se l'est forgé en tant qu'avocat en 1972
il défend Roger Bontemps accusé de
complicité dans une prise d'otage
meurtrière bontemp est condamné et
guillotiné dans la cour de la prison de
la Santé Robert badentter assiste à son
exécution bonttin n'avait pas tué
ils l'ont condamné à mort et il a été
exécuté et c'est à partir de ce moment-l
que je suis devenu pas seulement comme
je l'étais avant un parmi d'autres qui
étai l'adversaire de la peine de mort
j'ai dit donc que je vivrai je
combattrai la peine de mort 5 ans plus
tard il parvient cette fois à éviter la
peine capitale à Patrick Henry condamné
pour le meurtre d'un enfant h n'aura pas
la tête tranchée il le doit pour
beaucoup pldoirie d'un avocat Maître
badinterre et c'est sûrement moment
important mais je ne crois pas qu'il
faille dire que la peine de mort est
abolie parce que Patrick Henry n'a pas
été condamné à
mort vous êtes en présence d'une
décision mais la peine de mort est
toujours là mais ces jours sont bel et
bien comptés nommé ministre de la
justice par François mit en
1981 Robert B fin à la peine de mort
Robert Badinter est né le 30 mars
1928 dans une famille juive d'origine
d'europee de l'Est en février 1943 son
père est arrêté par la guestapo à Lyon
après une rafle ordonnée par Klaus
Barbie il ne reviendra jamais des camps
en
1992 alors que desu accueille François
mitteran venu commémorer la rafle du
veldive le fils de déporté ne retient
pas sa colère
je me serais attendu à tout
éprouveré sauf le sentiment que j'ai
ressenti il y a un instant et que je
vous livre avec toute ma force d'homme
vous m'avez fait
honte combattant contre l'antisémitisme
et fervant défenseur des droits de
l'homme garde des saau il a également
mis fin au délit d'homosexualité une
disposition née du régime de Vichy il
était temps de proclamer aussi le droit
au corps de tous y compris des
homosexuels qui doivent être traités
comme les autres président du Conseil
constitutionnel sénateur Robert Badinter
a publié l'année dernière un livre
contre Vladimir Poutine jusqu'aux
dernières heures il a consacré sa vie à
la justice et à la
liberté bonsoir yel Bron Pivet merci
beaucoup d'être en duplexe de Vincen
avec nous ce soir la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale que vous vous êtes
à posté une très belle photo d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui avec lui à l'hôtel de laassy
la Présidence de l'Assemblée
qu'avez-vous ressenti à l'annonce de la
mort de Robert Badinter en fin de
matinée
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup de Français
j'ai beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup
d'émotion parce que il était la dernière
grande voie que nous nous avions en
France la voix de la sagesse de la
modération mais en même temps vous
l'avez passé en extrait la voix parfois
de l'indignation
et c'était un homme absolument
extraordinaire dans la photo que j'ai
posté vous savez il m'offre une boîte de
chocolat lorsque il vient déjeuner à
l'hôtel de laassé un homme très élégant
très délicat euh très noble en fait vous
êtes vous-même avocate avocate pénaliste
est-ce que il a joué un rôle dans le
choix de de votre
métier alors oui comme des générations
d'avocats je suis devenu avocate un peu
grâce à Robert Badinter parce que nous
avions nous sommes beaucoup à avoir lu
notamment l'exécution qui raconte le
procès buffet Bontemps jusqu'à
l'exécution et nous avons tous été
inspiré mais j'ai envie de vous dire
j'ai été inspiré en tant qu'avocate mais
j'ai été également inspiré en tant que
femme politique parce que
il a eu cette honneur et cette chance
incroyable de pouvoir en tant commomme
politique pour il a poursuivi le combat
qu'il avait mené en tant qu'avocat et
avoir une telle symbiose entre ce que
vous êtes qui vous êtes quel est votre
métier et après ce que vous portez en
tant que homme ou femme politique et
bien je crois que c'est ce que nous
recherchons tout cet alignement ultime
entre nos convictions profondes et ce
que nous nous pouvons porter les combats
que nous pouvons mener lorsque nous nous
engageons en politique et Robert
Badinter et bien c'était cela on parle
de l'abolition de la peine de mort en 81
mais il a mené aussi le combat plus tard
en tant que sénateur pour l'abolition
universelle de la peine de mort il a
bataillé pour la constitutionnalisation
de la peine de mort pour qu'on de
l'abolition de la peine de mort pour
qu'on revienne jamais en arrière et il a
mené ce combat jusqu'au bout de
l'universalisation de la peine de mort
et donc ça aussi c'est important c'est
ne jamais renoncer toujours se battre
pour ses idées et pour ses convictions
et vous savez j'ai déjeuné avec lui au
mois de novembre 2023 juste après la
marche que j'avais organisé avec le
président du Sénat il m'a invité à
déjeuné avec son épouse ellisabeth et il
nous on a parlé de la marche et il était
très ému de voir que les Français le 12
novembre s'était levé s'était dressé et
avait marché contre l'antisémitisme
c'est un combat qu'il a qu'il a mené
avec avec son épouse et donc j'avais
aussi un peu l'impression de le mener
avec lui et de porter ce flambeau là
merci beaucoup merci infiniment y elbron
Pivet d'avoir réservé votre réaction LCP
la dernière grande voix la dernière
grande voix c'est quand même quelque
chose comment avant de venir sur ces
combats et notamment l'abolition vous
vous le définiriez Bertrand Perrier pour
moi c'est la gratitude je le remercierai
toute ma vie de m'avoir permis et à
toute ma génération d'avocat la
génération bas d'interre d'être entré
dans la profession sans avoir l'idée que
on plaiderait pour la vie d'un homme et
non pas seulement pour sa liberté donc
je lui suis infiniment reconnaissant de
ça Paul Cassia même question un homme
juste un homme juste l'esprit de la
justice avant tout homme juste un homme
ferru d'égalité ferru de la dignité de
la personne humaine et qui portait très
haut l'idée de la République Michel cota
je dirais un peu en d'autres termes ce
qui la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui me paraissait
formidable chez lui c'est l'adéquation
totale entre l'homme ses conviction et
son éloquence politique il y avait pas
de de différence CIT vraiment un homme
entier il y avait pas de petite
déérobade non il était laïque
républicain et juste h HM et et Jean
garig l'esprit français c'est la formule
présidentielle est-ce qu'elle sonne
juste oui pour moi c'est le on va dire
le dernier grand humaniste le le dernier
représentant d'une d'une catégorie
disparue qui a vécu les plus grands
drames de l'histoire et en cela à
travers cette expérience et à travers la
culture qu'il avait de
l'humanisme républicain mais je dirais
de l'humanisme des lumières il a porté
ça tout au long de de sa carrière et
c'est c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui a tendance à disparaître
dans les générations actuelles si vous
le permettez une toute petite vous
confidence personnelle il se trouve que
j'ai perdu il y a de jours ma maman qui
avait à peu près le même âge que que que
lui et qui était comme lui issu d'une
famille juif de d'Europe de l'Est et
vous imaginez que Robert badinterre
était pour elle un grand
homme je toutes nos condoléances on va
revenir tout à l'heure sur ces sur ses
origines la Bessarabie c'est la mold vie
actuelle mais comment ne pas commencer
par le combat de sa vie l'abolition 17
septembre 1981 discours sur lequel il
est revenu dans l'émission rambobina
avec Patrick Cohen sur LCP regardz le
discours de 81 et puis le commentaire de
2021 par Robert
Badinter la peine de mort
ce en terme politique sinon précisément
quand on le voit pratiquer dans toute la
dictature le droit de vie mais le droit
de mort surout tout que ça roche l'État
à l'encontre de ces sujets je voulais
qu'on sache que c'était moi qui l'avait
écrit pas le cabinet pas d'excellents
collaborateurs que j'avais à cette
époque c'était moi pas les indication
donnée voilà vous ferez C vous ferez ça
puis vous corz non de la première à la
dernière ligne c'était le discours que
depuis si longtemps je rvais de faire
voilà le discours d'un rêve d'homme
Bertrand peyry c'est c'est l'avocat hein
qui monte à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale dans ce discours c'est une
pldoirie dans dans ce discours la fusion
de la plaidoirie et du discours il y a
évidemment l'avocat en permanence qui
affleur sous le politique mais c'est
vrai que c'est un discours très
personnel il le raconte il l'a écrit
pendant l'été de 1981 puisqu'il savait
que ce débat allait venir entre les
élections et la rentrée parlementaire et
il dit que des amis ont mis à leur
disposition en Bretagne un un un une
belle maison et que il a écrit ce
discours sur la terrasse avec la vision
du lointain et des bateaux et c'est vrai
que quand on regarde le manuscrit c'est
très beau parce que c'est un manuscrit
qui est très raturé très travaillé on
sent que c'est quelque chose qui lui
tenait tellement à cœur c'est le combat
de sa vie et c'est la consécration
politique de son combat judiciaire et
que chaque terme a été pesé par exemple
quand il dit à la fin une justice qui
tue on a vu l'extrait il avait d'abord
mis une justice de sang puis il rille
dit justice qui tue parce que le mot est
encore plus fort et donc on voit bien en
effet que c'est une pldoirie
parlementaire mais avec une fougue une
hardardeur au combat qu'on pourrait
attribuer à l'avocat qu'il a été Michel
cotaétait dans j'étais à l'Assemblée
nationale quand il a prononcé son
discours j'ai un souvenir absolument
extraordinaire de de son éloquence la
voix se répercuté vous savez sur la
voûte il y a une une sonorité
particulière de l'assemblée et à la fois
il y avait pas tellement il y avit pas
tous les députés d'ailleurs mais ceux
qui étaient là je peux vous dire ils
étaient ils ont pas pipé mot pendant
tout le temps du discours c'est un des
plus beaux discours je sais pas s'il est
parlementaire politique ou d'avocat mais
en tout cas le discours en soi est un
mouvement un monument d'écriture
jean-gar vous avez étudié de près ce
discoursou oui je il m'a été donné de
faire des des recueils des des grands
discours parlementaires il est évident
que celui celui-ci est un des des des
plus des plus épousoufflants et et
s'inscrit et c'est ce qui m'intéresse
aussi dans une dans une tradition dans
un héritage qui est celui de Victor Hugo
qui est celui de Jean jores notamment
qui a lui aussi commis des très beaux
discours pour l'abolition de la peine de
mort en 1908 avec des très beau dialogue
avec Maurice barrz qui lui voulait
maintenir la la peine de mort jees
Badinter il y a une filiation ah bah
évidemment on sent tellement ce ce
frémissement de deux de deux
intellectuels alors jores n'était pas un
avocat il était pas de cette République
des avocats qui a dominé la vie
politique pendant un siècle quasiment et
et et dont B d'Inter était peut-être le
plus beau flleuron le dernier des grands
des grands flleurons et là vous avez
effectivement cette cette fusion entre
le barreau et et la politique au service
d'un idéal c'est ça qui fait la force
c'est que c'est au service d'un idéal
qui est cet humanisme dont dont on parle
aujourd'hui h alors peut même si il sait
très bien que le projet va être voté
hein il y a pas de doute sur l'issue
pour autant ça n'est pas un discours
facile parce qu'il a face à lui une
opinion publque et l'idée de l'effet
dissuasif de la peine de mort et donc
tout ce discours est consacré à la
réfutation de cette thèse de l'effet
dissuasif à la fois par les exemples
étrangers par les études criminologiques
qui montrent que l'abolition ne crée pas
un surcroix de criminalité et puis par
son expérience personnelle c'est qu'il
explique à quel point lui-même même avec
l'exemple de Patrick Henry qui avait
crié à mort buffet à mort bonemps et qui
quelques années plus tard a été lui-même
meurtrier que l'effet dissuasif de la
peine de mort il en savait lui-même
l'inanité par l'avocat qu'il avait été
Paul Cassia j'imagine que vous avez lu
l'exécution ce livre qui est aussi un
acte politique avant de devenir garde
des saau qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie de faire cette biographie est-ce
que c'est d'abord 1980
c'est l'homme Robert Badinter parce que
Robert Badinter c'est une voix ça vient
d'être dit c'est-à-dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui maîtrise la parole il
maîtrise la parole parce qu'il a de
l'éloquence il maîtrise la parole parce
que il a aussi un parcours particulier
il a des anecdotes il a un vécu il sait
de quoi il parle c'est une voix voi x
c'est aussi une voix VO I e c'est un
homme qui a des idées qui a un fil
directeur dans sa vie et l'un de s fil
directeur c'était l'abolition de la
peine de mort qu' a mené à son terme
donc c'est une personnalité tout à fait
extraordinaire à plusieurs types cette
cause de
l'abolition vous pensez que il se l'IT
forgé avant tout dans le trèsfond de son
histoire personnelle euh la déportation
de de son père
Simon d'où vient d'où vient cette
conviction à l'origine selon vous sa
conviction profonde il me semble qu'elle
vient du fait qu'il est persuadé qu'un
homme ou une femme qui a commis un crime
ou un délit peut se rédempter peut
regretter ce qu'il a fait et peut
devenir meilleur c'est ça la base de son
combat Jean garig c'est l'héritage de
Victor Hugo ça c'est une c'est quelque
chose qui est typiquement inspiré de
Victor Hugo ne pas subir la loi du
talion montrer que la démocratie est
meilleure que qui s'inscrit dans une une
tradition on sait qu'il a été avec
ellisabeth Badinter le biographe de
condorset du marquis de condorset c'est
quel quelqu'un qui s'inscrit dans cette
vraiment cet héritage des lumières c'est
pour ça que c'est un humaniste et qui en
et qui et qui en fait à travers son
expérience effectivement de
d'avocat la la démonstration alors
ensuite de manière extrêmement précise
dans ce dans ce dans ce discours ça
c'est intéressant aussi de voir que les
les arguments sont des arguments qui
portent c'est pas simplement de l'enhas
c'est pas simplement un discours
décoratif c'est un discours de fond
j'allais dire presque technique mais
aussi un discours qui est habité par ce
souffle et vous vous vous le disiez le 9
février 43 c'était la le jour où a été
fait prisonnier son son père
ensuiteis déportation sinistre
incroyable coïcidence incroyable co
Michel cotta quand on lit l'exécution
donc qui raconte Le Dernier Jour d'un
condamné à mort bon temps qu'il a
défendu on comprend très bien quelles
sont ses convictions mais après aès il
faut convaincre un certain François
mitteron
expliquez-nous comment Robert Badinter a
pesé est-ce que est-ce que François
mitteran était sûr de ses convictions au
départ abolitionniste ou pas c'était
plus difficile d'Abir d'un ministre
ministre de l'intérieur d'un ex-ministre
de l'Intérieur de la 4e République qui a
vit
lui-même procéd et vu des des
guillotines euh alors je je pense que la
prise de conscience de mitteran doit
absolument tout à Robert
badater au début il l'a écouter avec
scepticisme euh et puis il pensait
surtout à jores et la la la très belle
phrase que qui que Badinter cite dans
son discours qui est la peine de mort
est contraire à la fois à l'esprit du
christianisme et à l'esprit de la
Révolution HM donc c'était au fond sur
ce euh sur ce cheminlà euh que en avancé
et puis finalement il y a une anecdote
absolument alors justement vous allez
nous la raconter mais on a les archives
parce que il y a une archive émission
très connue he carte sur table François
mitéran est invité face à Alain duamel
et Jean-Pierre elkabache on est le 16
mars 1981 il reste 5 condamnés François
mitteran les les GR ira-t-il s'il est
élu la réponse de
l'intéressé je dis ce que je pense ce à
quoi j'adhère ce à quoi je crois ce à
quoi rattache mes mes adhésions
spirituelles ma croyance mon souci de la
civilisation je ne suis pas favorable à
la peine de mort donc vous les graciriez
je feraiis ce que j'aurais à faire dans
le cadre d'une loi que j'estime
excessive c'estd régalienne un pouvoir
excessif donner un seul homme disposer
de la vie d'un autre mais ma disposition
est celle d'un homme qui ne ferait pas
procéder à des exécutions capitales je
vais je
alors Michel cotta cette anecdote de la
coulisse de ses propos tenus la couisse
donc juste avant l'émission c'est Robert
bentter qui me l'a raconté lui-même en
en décembre dernier donc c'est assez
c'était marquant dans son esprit euh
alors au fond il y avait un espèce de
jeu une espèce de jeu entre mitéran et
lui mitéran lui disait tout le temps oh
écoutez votre peine de mort vraiment
votre peine de mort alors il refaisait
miteran quand il il adorait imiter les
gens donc il refisait oh votre peine de
mortert vraiment et puis il a quand même
fait
naturellement les cinq pages que
demandait que demander François miteran
sur sur la justice et au dernier moment
il est allé lui-même avant que François
mitteran ne quitte son domicile il a mis
la page sur la peine de mort endessus du
dossier que sa secrétaire préparait pour
miteran et la secrétaire l'a vu faire et
har rry mais en tout cas la feuille é la
premiè que trouv un François mitan mais
il faut dire donc il l'a remercié après
fris mitan je ne sais pas je me demande
d'ailleurs parce qu'après tout Véran
n'avait pas le remerciement facile mais
oui sans doute en tout cas la fin de le
la suite de leur vie a montré une sorte
de complicité une expliquez-nous quelles
étaient les relations on a l'impression
que malgré tout si j'ose dire François
mitteran restera le modèle le mentor de
Robert Badinter
moi je dirais plutôt enfin je suis pas
sûr de dire le contraire en matière
parce il a beaucoup parlé de son
admiration françisanou oui mais sur la
sur la peine de mort notamment François
aveit une grande admiration pour le côté
militant militant de de mais quelles
étaient les relations entre les deux
hommes alors c'est assez curieux autant
qu'on puisse savoir parce que c'était
pas deux personnes particulièrement
démonstratives vous voyez alors il y
avait entre eux de la part de banatre
une grande liberté de ton à l'égard de
François miteran et ça c'était rare je
peux vous dire que les les gens
généralement sauf ses amis intimes
n'avaient pas cette et de la part de
mitéran il y avait une sorte
d'admiration pour cet homme qui parlait
si bien et qui était si convaincu et qui
lui avait
même transmis sa conviction et à la fois
l'impression que il était l'humaniste en
chef quoi et que son son visage
d'humanisme était plus important pour
lui que n'importe quoi alors ça l'agçé
toujours un peu qu'on soit plus
humaniste que lui mais enfin finalement
c'était une entente tout à fait
particulière oui j'ai lu j'ai lu dans
vos carnets que mitteran vous vous avez
dit un jour j'ai deux avocats Robert
Badinter pour le droit et Roland Dumas
pour le tordu oui tout à fait c'est une
une expression il avait le sens de la
formule une expression formul et Robert
Badinter lui a
pardonné le passé la francisque
oh ça vous on
rentr mais tout ça tout ça est quand
même discutable je veux dire donc il lui
a oui oui pardonné d'entrer de quitter
Vich et d'entrer dans la Résistance
quand son père malheureusement était
dénoncé par à Lyon par les Claus Barbier
la guest dans le combat de de de Robert
badinterre pour l'abolition il y a bien
sûr cette foi en la rédemption et la
capacité ultime de chaque homme à être
meilleur mais il y a aussi une haute
conscience de la faillibilité de la
justice humaine qu'il porte dans son
métier d'avocat il sait à quel point la
justice est contingente et que l'absolu
que constitue la peine de mort est
totalement incompatible avec l'idée du
doute l'idée de la possibilité pour la
justice de se tromper il y a aussi
quelque chose làdans il est très très
sensible à ça à cette fragilité de la
justice humaine qui ne peut se heurter à
au caractère définitif de la peine de
mort on va rester encore un instant sur
Robert Badinter l'avocat bonsoir maître
Henry Leclerc merci beaucoup d'être en
ligne avec nous on ne vous présente plus
grand tneur du barreau grand pénaliste
président d'honneur de la Ligue des des
droits de l'homme Robert Badinter
c'était votre ami depuis depuis 60 ans
je crois vous avez même plaidé ensemble
ans absolument nous avons plaidé l'
contre l'autre la première fois que j'ai
eu défendé la société Hofman la roche et
moi les victimes d'un scandale sanitaire
qui cel du stage queange c'est là que
nous avons fait connaissance c'était
dans les années 70 et après j'ai plaidé
beaucoup avec lui et nous avons beaucoup
échangé et bon je perd un ami oui vous
avez même dit que la non condamnation de
Patrick Henry était un chef-dœuvre de la
professions c'est un cheedœuvre
c'est-à-dire que plaider Patrick Henry
avoir voulu plaider pour Patrick Henry
après le le trasique éche échec de
l'affaire Bontemps vous savez qui avait
été condamné pour pour le crime de
clervau et c'était et
làat était totalement convaincu de
l'innocence de cet homme il avait lutté
très fortement et il avait perdu et il
avait décrit assisté à l'horrible
cérémonie de l'exécution et il avait
écrit ce livre magnifique qui est
l'exécution qui dit l'essentiel à ce
sujet et et vous aviez aussi au-delà de
la défense en partage la volonté de
toujours défendre les droits de l'homme
notamment les prisons la condition des
des détenus c'est un combat qu'on qu'on
connaît moins de lui
ben écoutez il n'a jamais cessé il a
d'ailleurs écrit un livre sur la prison
qui est tout à fait remarquable avec
l'aide de Michel per ENF un livre tout à
fait remarquable mais surtout il cessé
en en en 2000 à la suite d'un livre du
docteur Vasseur sur la situation des
prisonniers docteur vassur qui était
médecin pénitentire
une grande émotion s'est emparée du pays
et les assemblées parlementaires ont
fait des commissions le Sénat à ce
moment-là premère bandataire était
sénateur et il a participé à la
commission du Sénat j'ai d'ailleurs été
plusieurs fois interrogé par la
commission du Sénat et Robert mat mené
un combat et je crois que c'est lui qui
a inspiré le rapport qui a été fait et
le titre de ce rapport les prisons une
humiliation pour la République c'est
extrêmement clair et il jamais cessé et
je pense que c'est la dernière
conversation téléphonique que nous avons
eu il y a de TR mois je ne sais plus
exactement et ça portait justement sur
le le nombre accablant de prisonniers
dans les prisons françaises actuellement
le le les choix qui sont fait de
construire des prisons au lieu de
diminuer le nombre des prisonniers tout
en maintenant un système de répression
clair vraiment sur ce sujet il il était
totalement indigné totalement Milis
actuellement encore merci infiniment
voil est-ce que vous avez une anecdote à
nous faire partager pour terminer avec
lui un dernier souvenir je sais pas
lequel je sais pas je dirais peut-être
que
que l'anecdote à laquelle je pense que
j'ai raconté j'ai pensé tout à l'heure
donc ça revient c'est lorsque nous avons
plaidé pour deux complices deine devant
la Cour d'assise de Paris et nous
plaidions pour les complices c'était
Jean-Louis Peltier qui plaidait pour le
boss et quand nous aurons fini de
plaider tard tard le soir nous sommes
allés déjeuner tous les dîner tous les
deux dans un petit restaurant du du
quartier la et quand nous sommes revenus
la décision n'était pas prête et nous
avons remarqué que la se chapelle était
éclairée nous y sommes allés et il y
avait un concert alors nous a laissé
entrer et nous avons entendu avecam foir
absolument sublime et nous étions là
tous les deux à se dire on sort de
l'horreur et on arrive dans le sublime
merci c'est c'est curieux mais c'est un
souvenir d'émotion et d'amitié que j'ai
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup merci Maître
henré Leclerc d'avoir partagé votre
émotion avec nous je voudrais qu'on
parle du style vous avez commencé à en
parler un peu Paul classia en nous
disant que c'était une voix on nous dit
la dernière voix mais quel style il y a
une silhouette émaassé il y a un sens du
verbe et des silences nouvel extrait du
discours de 81 et maître Bertrand
Perrier de la rOratoire va nous le
décortiquer il n'a
jamais jamais été
établie une corrélation quelconque
entre la présence ou l'absence de la
peine de mort dans une législation
pénale et la courbe de la criminalité
sanglante voilà on prend son temps quand
on est Robert badinterre pour scander
les phrases et ne pas hésiter d'ailleurs
à à s'arrêter sur des mots oui j'ai
l'impression en le regardant que c'est
vraiment un corps qui parle il est
engagé non pas seulement dans ses mots
mais tout son corps est tendu vers le
Parlement il se penche il est
physiquement tellement investi bien sûr
vocalement aussi avec ce jamais jamais
c'est redoublement et puis cet argument
d'autorité où il s'appuie sur toutes ces
études criminologiques qui dément l'idée
d'un effet dissuasif de la peine de mort
mais c'est toute sa personne qui est
vouée à ce combat même son visage ses
mimiques même sa bouche est tendue euh
et il n'y a pas un port de sa peau qui
n'est pas investi dans ce discours c'est
absolument magnifique il est d'une
sincérité totale et d'un engagement
absolu mais jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs
hein il était investi surtous les
combats son dernier combat contre
Poutine il était très inquiet du retour
de la guerre en Europe il a écrit
l'accusation qui est cet acte
d'accusation le jour où pladimir Poutine
serait soumis à la Cour pénale
internationale c'est quelqu'un qui
vibrait c'est ça jean-erc oui c'est
exactement et cette vibration la
retrouve dans sorte de trémolote de de
sa voix et et ça n'est pas simplement un
aroratoire he c'est quelque chose qui
vient vraiment de l'intérieur et alors
quelque chose qui me frappe aussi dans
cet extrait et qui m'avait jamais frappé
autant c'est aussi le côté je dirais
pédagogue et professoral de sa de sa
rhtorique car il faut pas oublier que
pendant des années il a été un
enseignant oui dans le passant par
professur de droit professeur de droit à
l'université moi qui suis ancien
professeur de d'histoire et Paul qui
aussi enseignant enfin il y a quelque
chose voyez dans la manière dont il a
avec son sa main il il il indexe les les
les les les les chapitres j'allais dire
de ce de de sa démonstration il y a
quelque chose de très doctoral de très
professeur il avait la passion de la
transmission voilà la passion de la
transmission Paul CIA vous vous êtes
intéressé au professeur qui était
d'université et pour nous je parle au
nom de beaucoup de de mes collègues
c'est un modèle c'est un modèle parce
que il a été professeur des universités
il n'a jamais oublié l'université quelle
que soi ses fonctions il est toujours
resté attaché à l'université c'est ce
qui transparaît aussi dans le discours
qu'on qu'on vient d'entendre transparaît
l'avocat transparaît l'humaniste mais
transparaît aussi le professeur des
universités et comment on le voit on le
voit ça a été indiqué par Bertrand à
l'instant par la
documentation qui sert de base à ces
discours j'en viens de le rappeler aussi
ce sont des discours qui sont objectivés
par des connaissances concrète et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on l'écoutait parce
qu'il était professeur des universités
les faits toujours les faits h les faits
et la réalité des choses la réalité des
choses et pourtant qu'est-ce qu'il a
pris cher comme disent les jeunes au
moment de l'abolition on va on va
retrouver là je vous donne la parole
juste après Robert balinter qui raconte
que lui et sa famille en 1981 malgré
l'adoption du texte rien n'était gagné
et il a enduré des trombons d'insultes
regardez c'était vous savez un long
combat combat euh avec une poignée
d'amis ce n'était pas un combat
populaire c'est pas un combat où vous
avez le soutien massif de l'opinion
publique pas du tout pendant des années
j'ai vécu éisabeth et même les enfants
et nous avons vécu dans l' haine à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un crime
affreux j'en étais le
responsable voilà extrait deobina avec
Patrick CEN qu'on pourra revoir dimanche
prochain c'était d'une dureté oui c'est
ce que au fond ce qui souligné c'est que
il plaidit pas seulement il PLA donc pas
pour les députés ça a été dit au fond
parce que il savait qu'il avait qu'il
aurait la majorité mais à l'époque où il
plaidait contre la peine de mort il y
avait 62 % des Français qui étaient
hostiles à l'abolition de la peine de
mort par conséquent c'est à eux qui
s'adressaient c'est toujours l'avocat
s'adresse toujours au fond veut toujours
convaincre son
adversaire et pas ses partisans donc il
s'adressait à eux et c'est ça moi je
trouve qui expliquait d'abord euh
c'était courageux ce discours il y a pas
de parce que en effet moi j'ai vu sa
fille accompagnée par des policiers à
l'école elle avait l'âge de la mienne et
elle était accompagnée à l'école par des
policiers parce qu'elle était menacée
j'ai vu toute sa famille menacé et lui
il a été mais physiquement très souvent
et et jusque tard ça on a l'impression
qu'après les années 90 c'était fini
l'opinion avait changé mais il y avait
encore et on voit d'ailleurs enc
aujourd'hui une hostilité BES anné é
absolument marqué il arrivait parfois
qu'encore aujourd'hui il soit comme ça
rangué voir insulté dans les lieux
publics euh écoutez une fois seulement
après la après la
l'abolition l'autre abolition des des
des lois contre l'homosexualité euh il a
été aussi agressé et j'ai le souvenir
d'une agression je vais pas raconter les
mots parce
que le cadre ne s'y prête pas mais en
tout cas je l'ai vu adresser être
agressé violemment
par oralement par quelqu'un dans un
endroit public euh et lui répondre d'un
trait absolument d'un trait à la
clémence absolument qui a cloué l'autre
par terre mais enfin euh il n'avait pas
branché mais vous voyez le le coup de
point n'était pas loin hm hm le le
combat pour la dépénalisation c'est
intéressant aussi on en parle moins la
dépénalisation de de l'homosexualité
c'était longtemps une infraction pénale
évidemment en fait ce qui me frappe dans
dans la parole de Robert badater c'est
aussi qu'il y a toujours une sorte de
colère sourde une révolte contre l'état
des choses et leur décalage avec ses
idées avec ses idéaux on le revoit aussi
dans le discours au 50e anniversaire du
veldive il y a là tout son être qui est
tendu vers cette révolte cette
colère cette rage presque dans dans sa
parole c'est jamais une parole gratuite
Robert Badinter par exemple Robert
Badinter il aimait pas du tout les
concours éloquence il y a des concours
des il est jamais venu parce queant il
manquait pas lui-même mais il n'en
manquait pas mais il ne manquait pas de
la vraie éloquence c'est celle qui veut
changer le monde pas une éloquence
policée de salon c'est quelqu'un qui
avait une tellement haute idée de la
parole de ce qu'elle peut faire dans le
monde que finalement les soirées où on
se pose des
questions non alors si il a reçu les
jeunes d'éloquantia ce programme de
formation à la prise de parole en scène
Saint-Denis parce que ça l'intéressait
c'est de dialoguer avec les jeunes mais
ça l'intéressait pas d'assister à un
prix d'éloquence il y a une dimension
aussi qu'on connaît moins c'est les
droits de l'homme et les combats
internationaux si un citoyen peut saisir
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est grâce à lui Paul casscia
absolument Myriam et ce point est
fondamental il est pas très connu il
nous concerne toutes et tous le 9
octobre 19801 est une date décisive dans
l'histoire de France dans l'histoire
juridique dans l'histoire politique de
France seulement parce que la peine de
mort a été abolie mais aussi parce que à
cette date signé par François mitteran
et Robert banatter a été pris un texte
qui nous permet aujourd'hui encore je
parle sous l'autorité de mon voisin
avocat au Conseil d'État la Cour de
cassation à nous individus de saisir
directement une juridiction européenne
qui s'appelle la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et ce point est
décisif dans la qualité de notre État de
droit nous avons fait partie le 9
octobre
1981 du système européen des droits de
l'homme et c'est grâce à Robert Badinter
que nous devons cette élévation de notre
stand pour quelle victoire concrètement
ça peut permettre à à quel citoyens
d'obtenir quoi sur quel sujet et bien ne
serait-ce que cette semaine la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a jugé
que les NAS policière qui était pratiqué
en France jusqu'en 2021 était
irrégulière était régulière et toutes
les semaines il y a des arrêts de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui viennent condamner ou vérifier en
tout cas que la France a respecté le
système européen des droits fondamentaux
voilà alors des acquis de droits
fondamentaux en Europe mais qui sont on
le voit hein souvent remis en cause par
des coups de boutoir notamment de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui sur ces
mêmes cette même cours et cette même
convention Jean gar oui je voulais
revenir sur la la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité quand même parce que
c'était depuis Vichy depuis 1942 que les
homosexuels n'avaient pas droit à à la
même majorité sexuel que que que les
autres ce qui fait que on les assimila à
des à des pédophiles en quelque sorte et
vous avez des milliers d'homosexuels qui
ont qui ont souffert qui ont été même
emprisonnés pour ces pour ces pour ces
délits et ça a été une libération ça a
été un moment me semble-t-il très
important dans l'histoire de la
communauté homosexuelle appelons-la
comme ça pour justement grâce à lui
s'émanciper de cette de cette chape de
plomb qui pesait sur y compris
symboliquement je veux dire que c'était
quand même quelque chose qui a été vécu
de de manière très forte par par eux et
puis alors il y a toute la dimension
internationale ensuite de du bas d'Inter
avec la Commission internationale pour
sur la Yougoslavie qui a qui a qui qui a
joué un rôle très très important aussi
pour commission sur sur la paix en
Yougoslavie dans les années 90 ça a été
là aussi un rôle très très important et
alors dernière chose parce que j'essaie
de de grapiller au
passage on pense quand même
irrésistiblement aussi à au discours de
Simon veille en 1974 on y pense tous les
origines c'est vrai aujourd'hui on a
tous pensé à Benre et on a pensé à SIM
et évidemment aussi toutes les injures
subies toute la et voilà il y a il y a
un fil conducteur quand même c'est pas
un hasard si c'est les peut-être les les
deux grands discours parlementaires qui
se dégagent de l'histoire de la de de la
République par c'est des discours de
courage même si on peut considérer que
il n'y a pas le talent oratoire chez
chez Simone veille qu'on trouve chez
chez chez chez Badinter mais c'est quand
même quelque il y a il y a une filiation
quand même ça nous ramène aux origines
familiales de Robert Badinter la date
clé on en a parlé ce 9 février
1943 son père est déporté le reste de la
famille va réchapper on est à
Lyon mais c'est évidemment une blessure
qui ne s'est jamais refermée d'ailleurs
la la famille Badinter la mère et les
deux frères seront des enfants cachés
seront une famille cachée en savoix
quelle place a cette histoire- là dans
son combat Paul CCIA une place
évidemment décisive Robert bater a dû
fuir Paris pour Nant puis Nant pour Lyon
puis lon pour une une une autre ville de
province il a vécu ça ce qui est déjà un
choc
tout à fait extraordinaire il a vécu
aussi la déportation pas seulement de
son père mais d'autres membres de sa
famille il a vécu la nécessité de se
cacher de changer
d'identité et toutes ces il a vécu aussi
l'attente du retour éventuel de son père
à l'hôtel lutessia et raconte ça
d'ailleurssolument l'absence
insupportable il na jamais il n
évidemment jamais revenu il a été
déporté à sobbor c'est ça absolument et
et tout toutes ces déchirures ont
évidemment forgé l'homme qu'il est
devenu et son combat pour l'égalité
l'égalité entre les personnes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes l'égalité
entre les orientations sexuelles
l'égalité entre les Français et les
étrangers l'égalité quel que soient les
confessions et l'histoire des Bad c'est
aussi une histoire d'attachement
viscéral à la France c'est pour ça que
ça a été un ch le choix de la France
après la Moldavie la Bessarabie c'est ça
ce qui a été c'est que c'était ils
étaiit particulièrement patriotes
français particulièrement donc assimilé
malgré la Bessarabie et je crois que son
père
disait il faut toujours un pays qui est
capable de de faire une guerre civile
pour l'ffire defus c'est un pays
intéressant parce qu' trouvaé
qu'effectivement il y avait des gens qui
se B P se déchire sur le sort d'un juif
là alors il faut y aller al il faut y
aller bon et donc la surprise et puis le
choc a été d'autant plus grand que il
est train de plein pied donc il
remontait dans son escalier de
l'appartement où habitaent ses parents
lorsquil s'est aperçu que la guestapo
était là et était en train de les
embarquer donc il est parti en courant
puis après il a pu recir ça mais il est
resté aussi vraiment très frappé par le
fait que malgré cette descente de la
gestapour il a été accueilli lui petit
garçon et sa mère ils ont été accueillis
par une famille qui ont toujours été
naturellement d'une discrétion parfaite
qui jamais dit un mot et qui les ont
soutenu aidé il est d'ailleurs retourné
je crois et c'était très émouvant dans
ce village il est il est
retournéoure juste bonsoir bonsoir Alain
jacubovitz euh merci d'être avec nous
euh vous aussi vous êtes un grand avocat
bénaliste ancien président de la Licra
avocat des partis civiles au procès de
Klaus Barbie euh vous avez bien connu
Robert Badinter on parlait de cette date
un jour près Robert Badinter est mort le
jour de l'arrestation de de son père le
9 février Simon Badinter euh coïncidence
à peine croyable
oui moi je je sais pas je crois pas au
signe du destin mais je crois pas non
plus aux coïncidenence euh je pense que
Robert binter est parti euh à cette date
du 9 février qui n'est pas une date
indifférente qui est qui va sceller le
destin de sa vie d'ailleurs je pense que
Robert Badinter ne serait pas l'homme
qu'il est devenu cet homme immense ce si
s'il avait pas eu le 9 février 1943 et
comme vous venez de le rappeler à votre
à votre antenne il aurait pu ne pas du
tout prononcer ce discours mémorable à
la l'Assemblée nationale si le destin
lui avait été fatal à cette date comme
cela aurait pu se produire et même cela
aurait dû se produire voilà c'était pas
son jour c'était pas son étoile fort
heureusement pour nous fort heureusement
pour la France mais je je je je pense
vraiment que il y a eu un déclic cette
nuit ce 9 février moi ce matin j'ai
pensé à la rafle de la rue
Sainte-Catherine et je ne pensais pas
que quelques heures plus tard on
m'appellerait pour me dire que rever bad
la terre nous avait quitté d'ailleurs ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
quand Klaus Barbie est jugé en France
c'est Robert Badinter le garde des saau
quand il revient de Colombie Klaus
Barbie est-ce que est-ce que c'est
est-ce que de Bolivie pardonnez-moi
est-ce que c'est c'est grâce à à lui
est-ce que Robert Badinter a pesé pour
que ce procès ait lieu bien sûr qu'il a
pesé mais il a pesé dans l'ombre comme
il l'a toujours fait il n'y a jamais eu
de mélange de gens chez Robert Badinter
il n'a jamais mélanger sa vie privée ce
qu'il était ce qu'il pensait l'homme
qu'il était à titre personnel avec les
fonctions qui étaient les siennes et les
autres fonctions qui étaient les siennes
d'ailleurs lorsque cllaus Barb est
arrivé personne n'a fait le parallèle
avec avec Robert binter mais c'est vrai
que c'est lui on le sait désormais il
l'a dit qui a demandé que lorsque cllaus
Barbie a rejoint le sol de France venant
de Bolivie euh via Cayenne et bien il
qui soit conduit au fort Montluc le fort
Montluc où se trouvait la baraque aux
Juifs le fort Montluc où Claus Barbie
avait torturé les résistants et les
Juifs et il y avait chez lui toute la
force du symbole bien sûr que T retour
en France devait se faire dans cette Jun
là là où il avait emprisonné ses
suppliciers alors bien sûr qu'il y a eu
un rôle important et j'imagine des
discussions dont nous ne savons rien et
dont nous ne saons jamais rien entre lui
et François mitéran sur cette question
parce que le moin qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il n'était pas nécessairement
d'accord surt sur ce sujet combattant à
la sable donc aussi contre le racisme et
contre l'antisémitisme
oui mais et ça c'est je dirais c'est le
c'est l'homme Robert Badinter et
justement il trouve ses sources dans son
histoire n'oubliez jamais lui ne l'a
jamais oublié que Robert baninter était
un fils de réfugié c un réfugié et
cétait un réfugié qui par la
méritocratie républicaine et est devenu
l'homme que l'on sait gravissant tous
les les échelons qui étai qui étaient
possi et son son histoire c'est
l'histoire de la France c'est l'histoire
de l'universalisme si sa famille s'est
réfugiée en France comme tant d'autres à
cette époque c'est pas un hasard parce
que c'était la patrie des droits de
l'homme parce que c'était la patrie des
Lumières parce que c'est cette France
dans laquelle Robert badater a toujours
cru celle de de cette France qui est un
phare de dans l'humanité d'où ces
combats pour universalisme d'où
l'horreur dans laquelle il tenait le
wokisme le communautarisme et le
dévoiement des droits de l'homme dans
lesquels nous sommes tombés désormais
voilà ça c'est c'est la vie de Robert
banatter et c'est pas parce qu'il était
un réfugier juif que seul le combat
contre l'antisémitisme l'intéressait
loin sans faux et d'ailleurs c'est pas
un hasard s'il a été un grand combattant
de la LIC c'est la dernière fois qu'il a
plaidé qu'il a revêtu sa robe c'était
pour plaider contre Maurice porisson en
19 juste avant de devenir garde des saut
h Maurice forisson le négationniste
merci infiniment euh merci beaucoup de
d'avoir été en duplexe par téléphone
avec nous maître alin jakubovitz vous
vouliz rajouter quelque chose Bertrand
Perrier oui évidemment il y a chez lui
un combat contre toutes les formes de
racisme mon dernier souvenir avec lui
c'était juste avant Noël c'était une
grande librairie pardon C sur une autre
émission et une autre chaîne mais il il
avait participé oui oui euh j'étais en
plateau il avait participé en duplexe il
était déjà un peu affaibli et à la fin
on lui demandait de raconter une
histoire face caméra c'est le principe
de l'émission et il avait raconté une
histoire de Rabin parce que malgré tout
au fond même si il était euh d'abord un
grand humaniste un grand Laï il était
quand même pétrie de cette culture et
c'était une histoire assez contrrouvée
de de Rabin où on on sent vraiment cette
inspiration là c'est peut-être sa
dernière apparition télévisuelle je ne
le sais pas mais c'était V novembre
dernier mais elle était très belle parce
que il était un peu émaé il était chez
lui et il racontait cette histoire de
grands Rabin à Jérusalem il aimait dire
d'ailleurs dans cet ordre qu'il était
républicain virgule laïque virgule et
juif mais il tenait à cet ordre oui il
est en cela très représentatif de ça a
été très bien dit de ces de ces juifs
qui ont émigré en France NOTAM V dans
l'entre de guerre parce qu'ils étaient
fascinés et attirés par ce que
représentait justement la République en
France je répète j'en suis un descendant
et j'ai vécu dans ma propre famille
cette fascination pour les valeurs de de
la République pour ce que pour ce que
représentait Victor Hugo jores clémau et
les autres si vous voulez et et et on
voit bien chez lui qu'il est d'abord
habite par cette passion de de la
République mais évidemment sans renier
c'estes c'est ce qu'est sa judéité et je
voudrais rajouter que lorsqu'il définit
la laïcité il dit quelque chose de très
intéressant il dit que la laïcité c'est
la liberté de de croire c'est l'égalité
entre les les les religions et c'est la
fraternité de l'un autre donc la laïité
c'est la France voilà c'est la
République Michel cota al je pense le
dernier la dernière fois que que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le voir il se il était
très inquiet c'est-à-dire en décembre
dernier son inquiétude était il
manifesta son inquiétude pas seulement
pour le coup naturellement retour de
Poutine dont il avait déjà sur lequel il
avait déjà écrit mais euh il voyait
quand même une France se se désagréger
et il avait peur de ça et et il avait
peur du naturellement de l'antisémitisme
même si effectivement ça nétait pas
uniquement un antisémite mais il avait
peur de ça et c'est la première fois que
je l'ai vu angoisser lui qui pourtant
après avoir mené tous ces combats était
par moment pessimisme optimisme sur
l'homme était optimiste sur l'homme et
là pour la première fois il était abattu
voilà il était inquiet oui entre
l'Ukraine et euh et la guerre à Gaza ça
fait beaucoup on peut l'imaginer je
crois qu'on est en ligne avec marielise
Lebranchu euh bonsoir même en duplexe
formidable merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes ancienne garde des saau
sous Lionel Jospin vous avez je
crois côtoyer Robert Badinter au point
que il vous aurait donné quelques
conseils pour être une une bonne
ministre de la Justice racontez-nous
oui j'avais naturellement appelé Robert
Badinter pour lui dire voilà je suis
vendô c'est pas simple et il m'a en fait
dit avec des belles phrases que je ne
saurais répéter j'arrive et il m'a il
m'a expliqué que j'allais faire face à
il alors il c'était global ils vont vous
demander de revoir l'ordonnance de 45
ils vont vous demander d'emprisonner
d'avantage ils vont vous demander et
Cera et cetera et donc résistere c'était
le premier mot résister à ce qui peut
vous apparaître comme une grande
majorité de de votre pays résiste
ensuite on a longuement parlé de la
pénitentiare il m'a dit lorsque j'ai eu
l'honneur de demander l'abolition de la
peine de mort j'ai été obligé d'accepter
en même temps qu'il y ait des peines
longues or les peines longues sont une
aberration vous devez lutter pour que
chacun puisse réfléchir à la dignité de
celui qui rentre dans la prison et qui
ne voit pas le moment où il en sortira
c'est indigne de nous donc donc vous
devez travailler pour que les peines
longues ne soient plus et en particulier
ne soient jamais des peines planchées et
puis bien sûr on a beaucoup parlé des
surveillants de prison de de la pression
de tout le monde sur ces ces gens qui
sont le dernier maillon de la chaîne de
la République et ensuite il m'a dit et
une fois tout ça dit et fait je j'ai
alors en souriant il aimait bien rire
j'ai un ordre à vous donner quitte la
France le plus souvent possible pour
aller porter la demande d'abolition de
la peine de mort là où elle existe
encore et quitter la France le plus
souvent possible parce que la Cour
pénale internationale n'est pas encore
reconnue par tous or elle sera l'arme de
la paix
et je l'ai vu plusieurs fois et la
première fois qu'il m'a rappelé lui-même
c'était pour dire bon alors on en est où
de la CPI et il m'a il s'est interrompu
lui-même en disant vous allez penser que
je suis le seul à m'occuper de la CPI en
France parce que vous n'en entendez
jamais parler mais justement comme vous
n'en entendez jamais parler je compte
sur vous pour en parler tout le temps et
c'était très intéressant parce que
j'avais un grand homme devant moi qui
m'impressionnait il faut le dire mais
qui me mettait au même niveau à avec des
missions euh et tout en me disant quand
même ben vous allez peut-être me rendre
des comptes quoi voilà céit merci c'est
c'est formidable de partager avec vous
ces ces anecdotes euh on a l'impression
qu'il y a comme ça des passages de
relais entre entre les génération on a
on a parlé des engagements
internationaux on a parlé des des
prisons il y a une institution alors on
est à la Chaîne Parlementaire côté
Assemblée nationale mais je crois qu'il
aimit beaucoup le Sénat il y a passé
plusieurs décennies je crois euh quel
était cet attachement au Palais du
Luxembourg
le droit le droit parce que il avait
raison et on en a parlé parce que
quelquefois l'assemblée national on
accepte amendement puis amendement puis
amendement puis amendement sans bien
regarder que tel amendement par rapport
à tel autre n'est pas n'est pas
possiblement acceptable en terme de
droit et ce qu'il aimait au Sénat c'est
que quand un texte arrivait que ce soit
projet ou proposition et bien on
balayait d'abord les cohérence
éventuelle on balayait d'abord la
constitutionnalité on regardait la vie
du Conseil d'État calmement le droit
pour lui c'était la chambre du droit et
je pense qu'il n'a pas tort moi j'ai vu
quelquefois dans d'autres moments de de
ma vie politique le Sénat rectifiait
avec raison ce qui se trouvait dans le
texte sortant de l'Assemblée nationale
il y avait ça et je pense qu'il y avait
le temps le temps HM euh il n'aimait pas
le bruit de l'Assemblée nationale
euh même si il avait un ESP un respect
immense pour nos institutions
l'assemblée comprise mais il aimet le le
temps au Sénat c'est le calme des débats
mais le ton et un jour je je viens pour
discuter euh de notre désaccord nous
avions un désaccord entre le certain
nombre de représentant du gouvernement
et lui sur la
pénalisation de la des clients de la
prostitution et il me disait voyez vous
allez trop vite vous allez trop vite
vous avez un enthousiasme qui
m'intéresse que j'aime bien mais je
pense que vous faites fausse route et ce
n'est pas parce que je suis celui qui
soi-disant vous impressionne que vous
n'avez pas le droit de me dire que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi mais ce
n'est pas parce que vous êtes garde des
saau de ce gouvernement que je ne vais
pas vous dire que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous et c'était en
souriant et ilit vous voyez au Sénat ça
fait 3 jours qu'on travaille sur cette
question et je pense que vous n'avez pas
assez
décortiquer tous les points et je
voudrais bien que vous m'écoutiez céit
merci infiniment merci beaucoup merci
vraiment mariiseber pour pour ce
témoignage qui fourmit d'anecdotes et et
d'émo
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
on a tous compris que on avait perdu une
très grande voix la présidente de
l'Assemblée a dit la dernière grande
voix alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment
comment on hérite comment on transmet
comment on n'oublie pas où sont les voix
qui pourraient émerger pour passer le
relais de l'héritage de Robert badanter
de de deux choses mariise branchu a
commencé à à l'évoquer c'est l'état de
droit être fidèle à l'état de droit on
n' pas évoqué le Robert B président du
Conseil constitutionnel mais il a été
aussi cela ce gardien du droit contre
les passions humaines et puis
l'abolition universel c'est ça restait
un combattant Robert a toujours
considéré que l'abolition en France
n'était rien d'autre qu'une étape et si
nous sommes tous et toutes les enfants
de Robert Badinter et bien il nous faut
poursuivre ce combat là Paul Cassia même
question serons-nous les les dignes
héritiers de Robert Badinter sa voix va
manquer forcément je sais pas si je peut
être un digne héritier mais ce que je
sais c'est que Robert vanater m'inspire
tous les jours euh j'ai eu la chance de
le rencontrer j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir débattre avec lui et ces idées
ont infuisé en moi ces idées
d'universalisme d'universalité des
droits de l'homme de promotion des
libertés publiques de défense de la
l'image de la France comme pays de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme de
respect de la dignité de la personne
humaine et ce sont toutes ces idées-là
j'essayie de les mettre en pratique au
quotidien vous lui voyez un héritier
Michel cotta aujourd'hui non pas
aujourd'hui mais par définition les
héritiers peuvent surgir tout de même
même si même s'il se cachent à un moment
j'espère qu'il y en aura mais
effectivement jeen vois pas euh moi que
ce qui me frappe beaucoup aussi dans
dans Robert Badinter c'est cette cette
invention presque du droit
eu du droit des délinquants du droit des
euh des criminels du droit des voleurs
d'avoir leur dignité et c'est vrai qu'il
a beaucoup réfléchi à des cellules qui
soit convenable à des traitements de
prisonniers qui soi convenable et je
trouve que c'est quand même un grand
progrès dans l'humanité merci beaucoup
vous aurez le mot de la fin Jean Garg
d'un mot hein mais pour dire ce qui ce
qui rend difficile d'avoir un héritier
de Robert badentter c'est qu'il a
traversé des périodes de l'histoire qui
l'ont forgé qui ont forgé l'homme
l'homme qu'il était mais en se référant
à lui évidemment peut-être qu'on peut
construire dans la fidélité à ses idées
la politique c'est d'abord la fidélité à
un certain nombre d'idées et c'est
sortir un peu des des contingences de de
notre zapping permanent de de la vie
publique et son message ce qu'il nous
laisse est très important je dirais même
urgent dans la situation politique dans
laquelle nous sommes je remercie
infiniment d'avoir été avec moi pour
parler de Robert Badinter pendant 1
heure sur LCP merci à toutes les équipes
qui m'ont aidé à préparer cette émission
Dario borgog et Ivan avion pour le
duplexe avec yel Bron Pivet et bien sûr
Jean-Pierre Montanet Fanny Salou
Charlotte Barbaza à très vite à la
semaine prochaine très bon weekend
[Musique]
à